yeah
masara who already struggles with a
chronic disease is suffering from
pneumonia
she managed to obtain an entry visa for
Egypt which was later revoked by its
consulate after a long and difficult
journey to get to Sudan's border with
Egypt she found herself stranded now
admitted to a hospital in the Border
City of wadihalfa
closed since Friday
what the hell for Hospital which has
limited capacity is receiving more than
100 patients every day mostly from those
stranded on the border as a result of
the war in Sudan which has led to a
shortage of medicines and other basic
medical supplies
many of the patients were examined but
cannot get their hands on the prescribed
medicines their health is deteriorating
many of them who have escaped the war
are now on the verge of death
came to the hospital to get him the
diabetes pills but they're out of stock
what should I do leave him to die what
will become of us especially now we
don't have passports after our home was
destroyed I need a solution
kidney patients who need regular
dialysis are at greater risk
I've been on dialysis for the past four
years if I or any other patient miss a
session will pay a heavy price by next
Tuesday we will have no chance of
another session and will be left to the
mercy of God
in the refugee camps the situation is
even worse people are facing many
diseases especially young children and
the elderly are in no better shape
either with the absence of Health Care
and a delayed entry into Egypt where
they have a better chance of getting
medical treatment
chronic disease deteriorating health
conditions and a shortage of medical
supplies are adding to the many other
factors worsening the suffering of the
refugees stranded on the Sudan Egypt
border and their situation is not
getting any better Alpha